الى جنوب لبنان
مازن هل اعلن حزب الله اي شيء عن هذا
الحدث الامني غير الواضح حتى اللحظه وماذا
عن اعلانه استشهاد اثنين من
عناصره نعم في الواقع حسن حزب الله يتصرف
حتى الان وكانه غير معني باي روايه
اسرائيليه عن حدث امني هو ما اكد عليه وفق
بياناته ووفق المصادر التي تواصلت معها
انه نفذ اليوم هجمات باتجاه ثكنه شومير
ومنطقه ومنطقه شومي والمستوطن وتلك
المواقع التي اطلق باتجاهها عشرات
الصواريخ لا سما خلال ساعات الصباح الباكر
وبالتالي وفق الاعلانات المتتاليه من حزب
الله تتعلق بان العنوان الان بات واضحا هو
استهداف المستوطنات الاسرائيليه التي
تحولت بالنسبه للحزب الى ثكنات عسكريه
وبالتالي هو يتصرف انطلاق
من هذه المعادله ان كل هذه المستوطنات
التي تنتشر على الحدود الجنوبيه للبنان هي
باتت بمثابه اهداف عسكريه لا تتضمن اي
مستوطنين ومن هنا يفهم هذا الاستهداف
المتتالي والذي حصل اليوم وحصل بالامس من
خلال استهدافه الست مستوطنات عمليا حزب
الله اليوم نعم اعلن عن استشهاد مقاتلين
ليرتفع عدد شهدائه في هذه المواجهات الىى
نحو
116 شهيدا منذ اندلاع المواجهات في من
اكتوبر وعمليا يمكن الحديث الان عن مجموعه
من المتغيرات على مستوى كيفيه تعامل حزب
الله والتكتيكات التي بات يعتمدها في هذه
المعركه هو بات يستخدم اكثر مواد وقنابل
وصواريخ لالحاق اكبر قدر ممكن من الاصابات
في صفوف الاسرائيليين وتحديدا ليس فقط عند
الخط الشرط الحدودي الاول حيث تقع المواقع
العسكريه ولكن في عمق تلك المناطق من خلال
استخدام سواء المسيرات الانتحاريه والمحله
بالمتفجرات بالاضافه الى صواريخ البركان
وغيرها وهنا لابد من الاشاره بان قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حسن باتت تستخدم
الطيران بشكل واسع النطاق هي تنفذ غارات
ليس فقط على محيط البلدات الحدوديه ولكنها
تضرب في عمق البلدات بالاضافه الى وصولها
الى قضاء جزين قبل قبل ايام من خلال تنفيذ
احدى الغارات وبالتالي كل هذه المعطيات
تجي بان الامور على مستوى الجبهه الجنوبيه
للبنان باتت تتطور بشكل كبير وهنا لابد من
الانتقال الى شق اخر يرتبط بكيفيه مقاربه
حزب الله والحكومه اللبنانيه لكل الرسائل
التي وصلتها غربيا وايضا من خلال
التصريحات الاسرائيليه فيما يتعلق بالقرار
1701 الكلام كان واضحا اليوم و بعجاله حسن
على مستوى رئيس حكومه تصيف الاعمال عندما
قال بان لبنان ملتزم بالقرارات الدوليه لا
سما 1901 ولكن شرط انسحاب اسرائيل من كامل
الاراضي التي تحتلها وذلك في اشاره الى
مزارع شبعه الى تلالك فرشوط اللبنانيه
المحتله والى النقاط
ال3 التي يعترض عليها لبنان على طول هذا
الخط الحدودي طيب مازن يبقى السؤال متعلق
ايضا بتوسيع اسرائيل لدائره قصفها ووصولها
الى مناطق على عنق اكثر من 30 م عن الحدود
مع ما يرتبه ذلك من رد مباشر لحزب
الله نعم في الواقع حزب الله يتعامل وفق
قواعد اشتباك متغيره يوميا بمعنى ان ل
لمعد نتحدث عن قواعد اشتباك ثابته كل يوم
تتغير هذه المعادله بمعنى ان كل ضربه
تقابلها ضربه كل غاره اسرائيليه في عمق
معين يقابلها استهدافهم في عمق اخر من هنا
نفهم اطلاق الصواريخ باتجاه المستوطنات
عندما تقوم اسرائيل باستهداف المدنيين كما
حصل عندما استشهدت سيده بالامس في مارون
الراس وقبلها استشهد مواطن في كفركلا
وارتفع عدد الشه شهداء من المدنيين
اللبنانيين الى 24 منذ انطلاق هذه
المواجهات في الثامن من اكتوبر كان حزب
الله يوسع من اطار عملياته وعندما ضربت
اسرائيل في عمق الاراضي اللبنانيه نتحدث
عن اقليم التفاح مثلا او عندما وصلت الى
قضاء جزين قبل يومين من خلال اطلاق
الغارات والصواريخ كان هنالك تطور نوعي من
خلال استهداف مواقع متحركه في داخل العمق
الاسرائيلي لم نعد نتحدث عن عمق كيلومترين
او اربعه كيلومترات ولكن الصواريخ بطت تص
الى مناطق متقدمه على سبيل المثال قبل
ايام استهدف حزب الله منصتين من ضمن القبه
الحديديه في مستوطنه كابري وهي تبعد نحو 8
كيلومترات في العمق الاسرائيلي وبالتالي
من هنا يمكن رسم معادله جديده هي معادله
متغيره يوميا كل يوم صباحا نحن ايزاء
متغيرات في كيفيه مقاربه الاستلاف
الاسرائيلي والرد المقابل من قبل حزب الله
شكرا لك مازن ابراهيم مدير مكتب الجزيره
من رميش في جنوب لبنان